Microsoft has become almost synonymous
computers as they gave rise to a
personal home computer that we all use
today no matter how much you prefer Mac
to Windows you have definitely come
across Windows one time or another
whether at work school or while visiting
your grandmother's house
but what if Bill Gates was a good boy
never drop out of Harvard what if he
never found her Microsoft what if
Microsoft never existed what type of
world we'd be living in today the first
thing that comes to mind when one thinks
of Microsoft is Windows so let's take a
closer look at how a reality without
Windows may have turned out there are
three major ways that this modification
could have changed the course of history
the first of which being IBM released
computing platform Microsoft actually
entered the operating system space when
they began developing an operating
system for IBM to use in the summer of
1980 IBM had just recently failed to
close a deal with the digital research
to license the then-popular operating
system CPM this is why they turned to
Microsoft for an OS Microsoft seeing the
potential in licensing out OS make sure
to keep the rights in licensing ms-dos
IBM who didn't expect other companies to
fall along and make computers on a
competing level with IBM didn't mind
Microsoft owning the rights to ms-dos
and this is what eventually gave birth
to Windows but what if Microsoft was
non-existent in this scenario
well IBM may have not outsourced the
creation of iOS at all and taken matters
into their own hands or they may have
returned to digital research and
renegotiated a deal with them or they
may have outsourced the OS to another
tech company in any of these outcomes it
is likely that IBM would have ended up
with the rights to operating system
running on those computers considering
this they probably would have started
licensing their IBM os/2 computer
companies that mainly focus on hardware
like Dell it's unlikely that they would
have kept the operating system to
themselves as they originally wanted
licensing rights to CPM if everything
else unfolded the same way this would
result in a future that would be most
like what we are living in today I'd be
almost already a computer giant at the
time and they would have simply
maintained their late in the market and
grown into the Microsoft that we know
today moving into the second possibility
we may have seen a world ruled by Linux
if IBM were to simply give up on their
push to owner rights to OS we may have
seen several years with Apple and IBM
dominating a computer realm with no
chance for a competitor
unless they were developed their own OS
well at least up until 1991 when Linux
would be released Linux is the
open-source operating system that is
free to use it's basically the Android
of computers and even to this day many
people prefer Linux by far over Windows
Linux enthusiasts claim that the only
reason that Linux is not more popular
than Windows is because windows already
had a good grasp on the market when
Linux came out and people simply didn't
want to change not to mention the hassle
of installing Linux on your own and the
fact that windows are better supported
by third-party software in our alternate
timeline however the rise of computer
giants like Dell and HP may have stalled
a couple of years under Linux really
caught on and we may have seen Linux
come pre-installed in the machines
similar to Android smartphones with a
lot more people using Linux the next
would have received a lot more attention
and developed a lot faster as well Linux
would have a pretty good chance in
developing into a popular operating
system but would have turned out as the
biggest Windows probably not if we take
a look at the smartphone market in the
US Apple controls about a third of the
smartphone market this is despite
several competent Android alternatives
coming in at a fraction of the price
like the Google pixel 3a this is because
iPhones are seen as a devices at better
hardware and software integration the
easiest phones to use and overall the
better product that comes with a hefty
price tag which is somewhat justified
but in the PC market Mac only controls
about 5% of the market share
despite this exactly being how Mac's
reviewed at the time and are still seen
today
so if Mac's had several more years to
catch on before a strong competitor like
Linux were to come out we may see Mac be
a lot more popular today
Mac's would have a strong support from
third-party developers like Adobe we may
have never seen a planter the downward
touch that reached in late 1990s and
early 2000s as a result we may have
never seen Apple into the smartphone
market we may be living in a world where
Mac's or a lot more prominent and
iPhones aren't even a thing and amongst
all of this Linux would be fulfilling a
role similar to Android the PC space and
then moving into the third possibility
we may have seen a game of survival of
the fittest with every computer
manufacturer creating their own
operating systems to go along with your
computer just like Apple this is
actually not as unlikely as it may seem
there's only a handful of manufacturer
to dominate the computer space today
anyways which are HP Dell Lenovo
aces and Acer
first of all in the US we probably
wouldn't have really seen a rise of Asus
Acer or Lenovo as they were all Asian
companies these companies have really
been able to penetrate the US market
because they offered the same Windows
experience but for offering a cheaper
price and American competitors but if
everyone was forced to make their own
operating systems these Asian companies
blue wouldn't have picked up much
traction in the US as consumers blue
wouldn't want to change from what they
were used to you can say that while
weight hasn't caught on as they're a
band from the US but that doesn't
explain why other Asian companies like
Xiaomi veero and Oppo haven't caught on
similarly our alternate timeline Lenovo
Asus Acer and Toshiba
really wouldn't have a chance against
American giants in the US and Western
markets it would really be between HP
and dawn who was able to win over the
consumer PC market Dallas much more
focused on the hardware side and didn't
have nearly as much resources as HP as
HP was already a huge company adele was
just a dorm-room start-up so the more
likely turn on HP developing their own
operating system in such a scenario we
would have seen HP dominate the consumer
side while Apple would dominate the
professional or more heavy user side and
as for Dell maybe Dell would have
started focusing on servers from the
very beginning and in Asian countries we
would see companies dominating that the
Western world has never heard about
similar to tension tour by do now that
is really weird and it's not nearly as
likely as IBM fulfilling Microsoft's
rule or Allah has become an Android of
the PC space but those are all just
possibilities if Microsoft didn't exist
and hadn't created Windows what about
all their other contributions like
Microsoft Office and of course the Xbox
Microsoft Office is a revolutionary
creation that has transformed the
workflow of millions of people
imagine having to manage finances it
without Excel or making a presentation
without PowerPoint today there are so
many alternatives with the most notable
one comes from Google with Google Docs
slides and sheets there are many
advantages to those like being free to
use and much more convenient as you
could use it on any device however
Microsoft Office is still to go to a
place for professionals and I think that
we'd all agree that it is superior to
Google's offerings in terms of user
experience which we would expect as
Microsoft Office is quite expensive this
is a room that I Dow IBM or any other
computer manufacturers would have
entered even Apple hasn't dabbled in
this space but there is one likely
candidate
with such an array of software which is
Adobe they've heated everything from
Photoshop and Premiere Pro to one of the
most commonly used file formats for
viewing and printing documents PDFs
Adobe would have been their clear
candidate developed something summer to
Microsoft Office there was of course
other giant software colonies that were
created around the same time like
Autodesk who are the people behind
Mudbox an inventor but those companies
really stray away from the consumer side
as they are really focused on
engineering and 3d modeling so I think
that would be a lot more likely that
we're using Adobe PowerPoint rather than
a counterpart from someone else like
Autodesk and what about one of the most
popular gaming systems that Xbox well if
Microsoft wasn't there to release the
Xbox Sony who definitely have filled
their space their successful PlayStation
series would be even more successful
that ps2 may have reached 200 million
sales and today at ps4 be bigger than
ever before or maybe we would have seen
another tech giant release an Xbox
equivalent around the same time this may
have come from someone like Nvidia or
maybe gaming giant Sega would have never
been forced to leave the hardware side
of gaming of course they had a slew of
other internal issues but without the
Xbox they would have had a higher chance
of survival Windows Microsoft and the
Xbox are by far the biggest
contributions from Microsoft but there
are so many other huge contributions
that have since died out like Internet
Explorer one of the main reasons
Internet Explorer gained a lot of
popularity was because they came bundled
windows the launch of Internet Explorer
basically marked the death of Netscape
which is the popular browser before
Internet Explorer but without Internet
Explorer Netscape would have never lost
popularity and if a o L bought Netscape
like they did on our present timeline
Netscape would have been a lot more than
4.2 billion dollars which is what a all
paid for it especially with the dot-com
bubble if a oh well word is to acquire
Netscape we may have never seen the rise
of Google at least not in the way that
we know them today
AOL would have controlled everything on
internet from the browser to the search
engine to email a oh well was the Google
of the late 1990s and if Netscape never
died without to rise up Internet
Explorer AOL may have very well retained
that position even to this day maybe
AOL would be the one to buy YouTube and
start developing self-driving cars who
knows the possibilities are truly
endless
and what about Expedia Expedia was
actually a project that was started by
Microsoft and
since then Expedia has grown to a 20
billion dollar company itself on top of
all of this
Marcus off has more than a handful of
other launches like the Microsoft
Surface Windows Phone Cortana MSN
Messenger hotmail Bing and of course
utter flop his wallet the Zune in the
end Microsoft truly created the computer
experience that we are all used to today
from Windows to Microsoft Office and
since then they have branched into
everything gaming consoles to travel
websites without Microsoft we may be
looking at a world where HP and a
pedometer at PC space with a low still
controlling the internet Google may have
never gotten so big the iPhone may have
never been released and Sony might be
bigger than ever before clearly
Microsoft is a company that has affected
all of us in one way or another in a
world without Microsoft would be vastly
different than what we live in today but
that's just one way that it could have
turned out if Microsoft is never
invented make a comment down below what
you think would have happened also if
you guys liked this barely mentions up
to like and consider subscribe and you'd
like to see more videos just like this
one
but until then I'm Hari I'll see you
guys on the next one